IT IS TUESDAY
IT IS TIME FOR “WETWEET!”
HERE WE GO.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
♪ WETWEET
WETWEET ♪
>> Jimmy: WELCOME TO "WETWEET!"
THIS IS WHERE WE, AS A GROUP,
DECIDE SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
POST ON TWITTER.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU FIVE
DIFFERENT TWEETS.
WE'RE ALL GOING TO VOTE ON
WHETHER YOU LIKE EACH ONE OR
NOT.
YOU ALL HAVE VOTING CLICKERS AT
YOUR SEATS.
[ CHEERS ]
YOU DO, YEP.
YOU CAN VOTE FOR ALL OF THESE.
YOU CAN VOTE FOR NONE OF THESE,
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THE RESULTS
LIVE EITHER WAY.
TARIQ, ROOTS, YOU GUYS HAVE
CLICKERS TOO --
>> Questlove: GOT 'EM.
>> Jimmy: WHATEVER TWEET GETS
THE MOST LIKES, WE WILL TWEET
IT OUT LIVE ON THE SHOW SO THAT
DURING THE BREAK YOU CAN ALL
LIKE IT AND "WETWEET" IT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S A SHARED EXPERIENCE.
OKAY -- YOU GUYS READY FOR
THIS?
[ CHEERS ]
OUR FIRST TWEET IS, "I WONDER
WHAT LIT UP OVER EDISON'S HEAD
WHEN HE GOT THE IDEA FOR THE
LIGHTBULB."
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
♪♪
SO IT WASN'T A LIGHTBULB THAT
WENT OFF.
HE HAD THE IDEA FOR THE
LIGHTBULB.
WHAT -- WHAT LIT OVER HIS HEAD?
DON'T JUDGE SO EARLY, GUYS.
I MEAN THIS COULD BE THE BEST
ONE WE GOT.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
I FEEL -- I FEEL UNSURE ABOUT
THIS ONE.
LET'S SEE THE RESULTS HERE, THE
AUDIENCE THEY ALL VOTED --
YEAH, NO, THEY DIDN'T LIKE IT
AT ALL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ SAD TUBA ]
NOT FUNNY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TWEET THAT
AT ALL.
>> Tariq: YEAH.
>> Jimmy: THEY DIDN'T ENJOY
THAT ONE.
>> Tariq: YEAH, A LITTLE
LANTERN WENT OVER --
>> Jimmy: YEAH, A LANTERN --
YEAH, A LANTERN WENT OVER --
THAT WAS IT -- THAT WAS THE
ANSWER.
THAT WAS IT.
NO -- EVERYONE JUST KNEW THAT.
DIDN'T SEE THE HUMOR IN THAT AT
ALL.
UNDERSTOOD.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GET RIGHT TO
THIS NEXT ONE.
THIS NEXT ONE SAYS, "TACO
BELL'S SLOGAN SHOULD BE 'IT'S
ALL THE SAME STUFF, BUT YOU GET
TO CHOOSE THE SHAPE.'"
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪
IT'S A TRIANGLE.
NO, NO, THIS IS A RECTANGLE.
THIS IS LIKE A SPHERE.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEE THE
RESULTS.
I THINK THIS ONE'S GOING TO DO
BETTER.
YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
♪♪
YES.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE GETTING WARMED
UP HERE.
>> Tariq: GAME'S OVER.
>> Jimmy: YEAH -- NO.
YOU THINK IT'S NOT GOING TO TOP
THAT?
>> Tariq: I MEAN THAT'S AS GOOD
AS IT GETS.
>> Jimmy: I KNOW.
THEY DON'T GO IN ORDER, BY THE
WAY.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY GET
BETTER, SO I DON'T KNOW,
YEAH -- THAT MIGHT BE THE BEST
ONE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET'S TRY OUT SOME OTHER ONES.
NEXT ONE SAYS, "FORGET THE
THEATER, THE BEST WAY TO WATCH
A MOVIE IS LOOKING TWO ROWS
AHEAD ON A PLANE AT SOME RANDOM
PERSON'S SCREEN."
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
♪♪
I WAS LIKE THAT -- I GO -- "OH,
WHAT IS THAT MOVIE, THAT LOOKS
GOOD?"
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
JENNIFER ANISTON AND
ADAM SANDLER, I'LL WATCH THAT.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT, LET'S SEE THE
RESULTS ON THIS ONE, YEAH.
YEAH, NOT BAD, NOT BAD --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
THERE'S STILL SOME LOVE THERE.
>> Tariq: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> Jimmy: OKAY.
WE GOT TWO MORE CHANCES.
I THINK THIS ONE'S COULD BE --
WELL, MAYBE.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
THIS ONE SAYS, "NO ONE HAS EVER
SAID THE PHRASE 'SOMEONE'S IN
HERE!' IN A CALM VOICE."
[ LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Tariq: I -- I LIKE THAT.
>> Jimmy: "SOMEONE -- SOMEONE'S
IN HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SOMEONE'S IN HERE.
SHH, SOMEONE'S IN HERE."
LET'S SEE THE RESULTS ON THIS
ONE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
"SOMEONE'S IN HERE.
SOMEONE'S IN HERE.
SOMEONE'S IN HERE!
SOMEONE'S IN HERE!"
ALL RIGHT, CALM DOWN, I HEARD
YOU, GOSH.
THAT LOOKS LIKE THE TOPPER SO
FAR.
>> Tariq: YEAH.
>> Jimmy: LAST ONE SAYS,
"EVERYONE IMMEDIATELY THROWS
OUT THE MAC-N-CHEESE BOX AND
THEN REREADS THE INSTRUCTIONS
IN THE GARBAGE, RIGHT?"
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪
THAT ONE MIGHT TOP 177.
>> Tariq: MAYBE, I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jimmy: THAT MIGHT BE THE
ONE.
>> Tariq: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jimmy: EVERYONE DOES IT.
THAT MIGHT BE THE ONE.
>> Tariq: TRUE, TRUE.
>> Jimmy: I FEEL THAT -- I FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THAT -- THAT'S
GETTING A LOT OF SMILING FACES
IN THE AUDIENCE.
LET'S SEE THE RESULTS HERE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THAT'S IT.
THE WINNER RIGHT THERE.
I LOVE YOU.
HEY.
♪♪
IT LOOKS LIKE NUMBER FIVE IS
THE WINNER RIGHT THERE.
[ DINGING ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
I'M GOING TO POST THIS DURING
THE COMMERCIAL BREAK.
IF YOU SEE IT ON YOUR FEED,
GIVE IT A LIKE, GIVE IT A
A "WETWEET" AND ENJOY.